[Music]
president biden in the white house
defending chairman of the joint chiefs
general mark milley after explosive
allegations in a new book claiming that
the general made secret calls to chinese
officials in an effort to undermine then
president trump and that he would warn
china if the u.s was going to attack
another allegation details how nancy
pelosi called general milley after the
capital riots and told him to protect
the nuclear codes from former president
trump milley reportedly agreed and then
took steps to potentially limit trump's
powers defense officials are telling
jennifer griffin those two allegations
are not true and the calls with china
were not secret and millie's office
issuing a statement today saying his
actions were routine and part of his
normal duties but republicans are
demanding answers with some calling for
milly to step down
i think general milley has a lot of
explaining to do and i think he ought to
stop bellowing and honking on like a
goose about white rage and
actually try to make our country more
secure imagine if tomorrow general
millie decides i think joe biden is
senile and so you know what i'm not
going to follow his orders i'm going to
collude with russia and china to prevent
us from acting or they are a future
president i don't think he's in his
right mind either because
it is the essence a military coup it
should be investigated immediately today
he should be questioned under oath if
not with the polygraph test whether it
happened if it happened he should be
immediately released of his duties and
court-martialed so here we go jesse
another one of these books with some
blind quotes nothing like that to get
the
juices flowing and cable news
i never say this dana okay
but i don't know what happened
but i do know that my sources in trump
world are saying that
he probably had his team leak this milly
to make himself look heroic and it's
blowing up in his face they say this guy
wants to be loved by the left and he
wants to be known as the guy that saved
america from trump remember he was a
part of this cabal with mattis and john
general kelly that we're going to
protect america from trump's base or
instincts i'm also told he's always been
very dismissive of civilian control
always kind of disrespectful when
civilians pipe up about what they think
the military should be doing and he's
always said the same thing the military
is independent the military is
independent it's actually not
independent it's underneath civilian
control and i know he's a four-star
general and i respect him for that but
he's also a four-star leaker because as
you know dana i have read every single
mainstream media book about 2020. and
this guy millie comes off better than
joe biden
it's almost like he would write his own
book like i don't know how i saved the
world
that's the kind of savior complex
that this general has so let's look at
the allegation let's say the chinese did
think
falsely that we were about to launch
some sort of strike on the chinese
mainland and
milly takes it information millie should
take it to the defense secretary then go
to the commander-in-chief and let the
commander-in-chief's administration
decide what message to send to china if
anything at all maybe keep him guessing
but he said he carved out allegedly the
commander-in-chief of the civilian side
from this this is the greatest intel
ever our biggest enemy thinks we're
about to hit him and you don't tell the
commander-in-chief that that's crazy and
to say we won't get a hitch you know if
we do hit you we'll let you know that is
not how the us military speaks to our
enemies and it also tells the chinese
that the civilian side is not even to
control the country that the us military
is running america and that's very
dangerous the other allegation which has
been widely reported was that he went to
nancy and chuck i'm not going to say
crying but he does cry and say listen
we're going to put up roadblocks in case
trump wants to launch a use of force now
anybody that knows trump knows he
wouldn't do that very reticent and
precise with his use of force and if
you're a republican if you're a democrat
it's dangerous for a democracy to do
that so
if he goes out there and testifies he
has to be honest with the american
people and flat out say i either did
this or i didn't and let the chips fall
so
uh thoughts and prayers to uh she's
going to blow up yeah i'm going to go to
her i was going to go to you but i think
that i can't contain
the energy
but like god's in prayer whoever has to
prepare him for his hearing on the 28th
i don't know who this guy thinks he is
that he has the authority to call his
equal in the ccp the chinese communist
party to tell xi jinping listen i'll
give you a heads up if we're coming
after you and he apparently it's nancy
pelosi who called him after january 6
and said i want i want this guy arrested
on the spot she allegedly was screaming
she was hysterical so he then calls
everyone together and says look the only
way this is going to work with the
nuclear football is we've got to go
through x y z look he is a political
i don't want to call him uh what i want
to call him but he is a political person
he went to the church with president
trump when president trump carried the
bible and when everybody on the left
said you know it was they they the
national guard moved everyone out they
didn't move everyone out okay and then
he apologized for walking with the
president this guy is a political
operative he's got no command his role
is to advise and you know what as if
afghanistan wasn't enough we now need
this to get him the hell out of the
pentagon he needs to be gone and shame
on him and by the way if he were any
kind of man he would have gotten
together and at least told the cabinet
for the 25th amendment as opposed to
running around if he didn't want to tell
the president and the fact that he told
esper is not enough for me that's not
enough he should have gone and spoken to
the president with esper who the hell is
he to call the chinese and that's all i
have to say a lot of attention was
already on general milley because of the
last month in afghanistan he is going to
have to testify at the end of the month
but president biden is already being
asked do you still have confidence in
general milly he said yes today do you
think that holds
we'll see how the reporting bears out
when the book actually gets to us and
then the reporters are done doing this i
mean jennifer griffin who's obviously
incredibly reliable uh
went against the report last night
saying that her sources are telling her
that everyone who was in the chain of
command that was supposed to be on those
calls was there up to 15 people that's
now been confirmed by an axios report
today josh rogan is also in agreement
with that what he's hearing from his
sources
his chain of command would be to go to
esper to have the secretary of defense
there when he's having these
conversations and he said that he
absolutely or his office said did not
violate the chain of command when it
comes to the nuclear codes
so i understand why president biden
isn't hurrying to fire his joint chiefs
of staff because twitter has their
panties in a twist today
men can wear paint boxers maybe your
undergarments if you choose to wear them
to the point about him being
someone that's a political figure yes he
went out with the president but there
was more that went on that day which was
also that there was tear gas used
against peaceful demonstrators it was a
first amendment violation and something
that's been widely looked into and for
him to say that he was on the side of
the people who were coming out uh to
peacefully protest there while the
president walked over um to the church i
think is actually the appropriate thing
that had nothing to do with trump
right it had it had nothing to do with
trump
she brought up the she brought up just
the walking dead that whole thing yeah
that was a really worse move on his part
so the people who criticized president
trump for
insufficient dedication to the rule of
law um many of them are praising general
milley for the idea that maybe he went
outside
you know the rule of law or the process
here's some
uh media folks a montage i love the
media he seems to be the greatest
patriot
that was on duty during the previous
administration i don't blame general
milley for any of this
in as much i blame donald trump god
bless general milly for straightening
things out i know that the chain of
command is sacrosanct i understand that
but this was an emergency this guy we
had a certifiable nut case in the white
house she thinks it's an emergency no no
this is the this is their cognitive bias
they will condemn you for saying the
same thing in the minute that barking
bag of nonsense and i'm not talking
about joy behar i'm talking about the
guy that talks like this no he's talking
about camera what's his name scott
schmidt steve smith yeah he's a nobody
there
they have like a dude they enter this
emotional delusional state that causes
amnesia where they can't remember saying
the exact opposite thing so what this to
me smells true
because of all the wannabe heroes who
were so emotionally invested in
fantasizing this good versus evil battle
in which they're gonna they're gonna
save the world from trump right and we
saw that a lot with the anonymous
sources and there were always people
that were gonna
you know prevent it prevent the country
from this evil man and then what happens
is they elect somebody that then puts
our troops in harm's way and creates
basically a a duck shoot in afghanistan
um the idea
if this is true okay again if this is
true it's a great idea for a segment
if this is true uh is that
can somebody actually believe that we
were going can anybody actually believe
that we were going to invade china back
in january if somebody
actually believed that that's the person
who's crazy that's it's millie who is
insane if you actually oh my god he is
going to invade the chinese
they're all insane
but i'm telling you that is what shows
you how delusional and emotionally
invested these people were that they
they lost their common sense the one
thing that i also hate about this story
is that it's going to sell books because
this is uh this is what they do every
single time yeah exactly we all i don't
say we all fall for it because it is a
news story but it it is so absurd to
think that this is the actual like
reason like he called is hysterical and
if it's true then they held the book for
exactly instead of getting it out there
and imagine if they hadn't held this
story there might have been a different
outcome in afghanistan because millie
would have been gone boom i'm tired of
the a lot of the books with the blind
quotes yeah i'm tired of them i'm so
tired of them i just can't stop stop
reading them hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else